the jello can experience anytime a
[ __ ] up thing happens to you
personally it's a chance to become a
bitter piece of [ __ ] or a little more
angry or a little more tired or a little
more depressed or to become a hero
anything whatever it may be any bit of
phenomena that comes your way as a
person you know anytime I fight like any
time something's really got to get done
that I've been procrastinating or any
time some shitty unexpected thing comes
my way I have a moment to decide am I
gonna react to this like I always react
the shitty things and like become
negative or dark or get pissed or can I
like react to it in a completely new way
and I think every time you do a new way
is my woogle concept you pop into a
different part of the multiverse it's a
little better than the one you were in
before and it's like a trajectory you
can go on when I was getting stoned at
the gym it for him I was imagining on
the treadmill that I was running through
the multiverse towards a healthier
version of me that I wasn't getting in
shape I was actually being inhaled into
a more on shape version of me that
already existed that's the kind of [ __ ]
I have to do to get myself to work out
yeah man it's a fun it's fun to do that
you know every single decision is like a
binary do you want to continue doing the
[ __ ] you've been doing over and over
again whatever it may be or do you want
to try a mildly new way and every time
you do that sure is [ __ ] it's not just
you that starts changing you'll notice
like other stuff starts changing too
around you you know things just tend to
generally get better yeah I think
there's there's thoughts that I've had
that a real similar to that where I've
wondered like if if multiverses are real
and they're supposed to be different
versions of you infinite versions all
over the universe why are we assuming
that this is the same every day you wake
up in the same version why are we
assuming that
to think about sleep is you just go away
then you come back with a memory of what
life was like before you went away and
you wouldn't notice if it just slid you
one notch to the right or one knot to
the left into the multiverse there's an
infinite number of Duncan's out there
with ghillie suits and gas masks on yeah
and you just slid over to the right by
letting a little old lady in front of
you and not even complaining when she
was driving 30 miles an hour okay
yeah like it's all right it's just a
nice lady let me just get around her
nice and slow and safe yeah that's it
wave to her hi and the more you do that
the more you do that the more you start
running into other people who are doing
the same thing you start ending up in
that part of the multiverse where many
other people are doing the same thing
yes and eventually you know
theoretically I think eventually through
those series of decisions maybe that's
where you can like that's where all of a
sudden you start realizing like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I'm in a temple I'm not even in
a in a reality that I thought I was then
I was just like in a deep state of
contemplative meditation yeah and you
know I don't know I mean there's all
kinds of interesting experiments you can
do if you've heard the term pro neue pro
noia it's the opposite of paranoia where
you think the universe is conspiring to
help you instead of hurt you yeah maybe
that's what we'll call a group pronoia
pronoia yeah yes yeah that's perfect
yeah yeah we needed a name that it just
came to us pro neue sounds like a dope
band yeah gonna go see Pro Noi at the
stable Center it's fun if you do that if
you really do imagine that every single
thing that's happening in your life is a
grand conspiracy to help you to advance
you to bring you or another way to put
it do you ever listen
I love listen to Christian radio this
guy was talking about a thing called
convection which is being inhaled into
the Christ so when you start like like a
black hole well I think like the white
hole I guess it would be a black hole
gobbling up planets but you're being
right strong into this into the super
intelligence and you're becoming like
you're being sort of lifted up into
the thing that makes the [ __ ] Big
Green Egg work like the thing that sucks
smoke up that's happening to you into
the divine intelligence and as it
happens you imagine you're the one doing
this stuff to get you closer to it but
really it's just your mind playing
tricks on you you have no choice
you're gonna be you're gonna wake up
you're gonna gain realization and and so
as that's happening you kind of you know
like you can quit something you can quit
drinking
you can quit smoking but you kind of
long for it but then sometimes you
notice you just stop doing [ __ ] that was
bad for you because you found a better
way to live and it naturally falls away
right that's convection you're being
drawn into the divine mind as that
happens the [ __ ] that looks like
austerity when you're like further away
begins to actually just be a natural way
that you act you just become naturally
more graceful naturally less inclined to
do shitty things naturally more tuned in
with like the 150 year old version of
you you know that that you sort of
naturally and that just happens on its
own because you were being convicted
into the Christ sucked into the Omega
Point the divine yeah
[Applause]